what are your thoughts on dopamine
detoxing is that legit does it work well
up until about six months ago i would
have said no um but my colleague anna
lemke she's been on the show oh great
fantastic um i have such admiration and
respect she's great yeah yeah just a
brief anecdote i was i directed
neuroanatomy course for the medical
students at stanford i should have known
who anna was and then one day she came
in to give a lecture on dopamine and
addiction and my first thought was oh my
goodness you know have to get her on the
podcast and have to i want her
talking to the world because it's such
powerful knowledge so if people haven't
heard that episode all right go listen
to chris talking to dr anna lemke i'm
going to listen to it i've listened to
all her podcasts that i was aware of but
again we were talking about it's hard
sometimes hard to find podcasts so i'm
going to listen to that um cannot listen
to her enough times
you know
the
the dopamine
you asked earlier about the arc of
dopamine and how long it lasts the the
one of the key takeaways from that book
dopamine nation that i've incorporated
in my own life is that there are certain
activities like cold water that create
long-lasting arcs of dopamine those can
be very useful for putting us into
long-lasting motivational states so
these are not big peaks and troughs
these are the pain of the cold water
followed by this long long arc of
dopamine wonderful it's kind of an
antidepressant positive motivator
natural stimulus i always say if you
don't have access to an ice bath cold
showers yes will work if you have a
shower that doesn't get cold enough keep
in mind that the original studies
showing this dopamine increase
had people get into 60 degree water
which is not that cold 60 degrees
fahrenheit for 45 minutes to an hour so
your water bill might go up but you
could just draw a kind of cool bath and
get in that up to the neck so because i
realize there are sometimes some cost
barriers to people that not everyone has
an ice bath
no
dopamine detoxing yeah so dopamine
detoxing is something that apparently
today my uh short-term working memory is
off i i swear i don't know yeah
i can't think of any caffeinated i can't
think of any um uh pharmacologic reason
for it but uh no excuses um
so dopamine detox i would have thought
was not something real
it seemed kind of silly to me actually
and i'll tell you why it seems silly and
why it still seems silly but why it may
have some utility but then anna
dr anna lemke told me that it actually
can be quite useful to take some time
and space away from
social media certainly from any
addictive drugs that's the treatment for
addiction and restore those dopamine
levels to baseline
now the way that dopamine detoxing was
initially described in the bay area
where it seemed a lot of tech types were
talking about it
was in terms of i heard something like
oh people aren't even looking at other
people's faces you know they're really
kind of living this like monkish
lifestyle like no food of that they
really enjoy no anything that to me
seems kind of crazy and kind of extreme
i mean i can understand not ingesting a
lot of highly palatable foods you know
eating some blander foods i can
understand not um certainly not doing
any prescription drugs or taking some
time off from caffeine caffeine
increases dopamine receptors which makes
the calf the dopamine that's available
more powerful at evoking the dopamine
response
i can understand avoiding certain
substances and behaviors but the idea
that you weren't going to look people in
the eye because there's gonna be too
much dopamine i mean i guess it depends
on who you're looking in the eye and how
much their look
positively arouses you but the fact of
the matter is that that's not
that's not a very rational way to think
about dopamine detox but staying out of
you know high intensity
highly rewarding activities
i think could be useful in terms of
reestablishing that dopamine balance and
everything we know from ana's work is
that
dopamine you know if you drive those
dopaminergic states too long addictive
drugs etc people can do this with sex
food drugs gambling
social media all sorts of things
pornography
you know what ends up happening is the
amount of dopamine that's released over
time goes down and down and down and
down and pretty much is traversing into
the territory of pain and then people
again are back to this thing where you
know they're scrolling internet porn
eight nine ten times or hours a day and
then they're wondering like why this
isn't effective for them anymore whereas
it was before what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you